Venezuela continues to devolve into
total and utter chaos arrests have now
been made in Venezuela
after soldiers tried to launch an
uprising against president Nicolas
Maduro there was actually an attack
launched against a military barracks in
Valencia Venezuela and two attackers
were killed at least eight people
arrested according to president Maduro
himself there was a video released on
social media which showed uniformed men
saying that they were rising against
what they described as a murderous
tyranny and this is all in the context
of months of protests in Venezuela the
ruling Socialist Party's deputy leader
called the attempted uprising a
terrorist attack on Twitter and there
has been tons of blowback not only to
what's going on in Venezuela but also
even to my commentary recently from some
who described themselves as being on the
Left defending Nicolas Maduro and Hugo
Chavez and criticizing me and it's been
very disturbing in the in the wake of
this totally undemocratic process by
which this election was triggered in
Venezuela an election whose details I
will get into in a moment I received all
sorts of messages from people saying
David you're an anti Maduro shill
because you're Jewish
you're an anti Venezuelan shill because
you're Argentinean and Argentinians hate
South America the Argentinians I seemed
I meet seem to dislike the United States
quite a bit it's not South America that
they dislike but I guess that's
anecdotal in both cases David you have
your view about Venezuela because
Venezuela is more brown Argentina is
more white and you're part of that upper
middle class Argentinian whatever that
doesn't like brown people which is
laughable the reason my family moved to
the United States in 1989 is because we
had no money in Argentina because things
were going so poorly in Argentina if we
I wonder if we had been part of the
upper middle class in Argentina I
probably never would have come to the US
and you'd never be even writing me a
message
right now because I wouldn't have this
program and the way that the
argumentation usually goes is hey listen
uh there was an election in Venezuela
and Maduro supporters came out and they
won the legislative elections and of
course the reality is the elections were
boycotted by the opposition because the
elections were widely seen as fraudulent
and invalid and completely rigged so
then the defenders the apologists of the
Maduro regime will say well if those
opposition individuals had voted then
they might have won well no number one
that doesn't appear to have been the
case number two there have been all
sorts of bogus charges brought against
opposition leaders to begin with and
lastly there was never a vote about
whether to have this legislative
election an actual democracy which is
not what Venezuela is would say hey
let's have a referendum it's actually
referendums not the right term but let's
have an initial vote to see whether we
are going to have this legislative
election instead you have an election
where no opposition candidates
participated the Assembly has the power
to rewrite the Constitution and could
override the opposition controlled
National Assembly and the key point for
me is whatever criticism you have of
American imperialism and the US interest
in oil in Venezuela or whatever
criticism valid of course you have of
ways in which the United States has
meddled in other Latin American
countries whatever criticisms you have
Venezuela is not a democratic country
period and it is wrong to support the
Maduro regime . the government of
Nicolas Maduro
is not a legitimate democratic
government the United States wants oil
so the opposition is all astroturf and
bad we're talking about a non democratic
government maduro's government has
purged voter ballots
they've disqualified the candidacies of
opposition leaders in elections on
totally bogus charges they've jailed
opposition leaders on made-up charges
with no due process they censor media
and prop up state media people don't
even know what's happening in their kind
some people don't know I want to be
clear qualified that with some these are
just a few of the things that the Maduro
chavez governments have done it should
be painfully obvious to anybody who is
an objective observer but sadly there
are people on the Left who love it I've
seen the most vile defenses from the
left of Nicolas Maduro over the last ten
days and it's truly disgusting
it's going to be interesting I'm going
to be in Argentina next week with my
family my family is all left-wing but
you've got the left that seems to sort
of like the nonsense that's going on
there and then you've got the left that
is critical of what is just
authoritarianism under the guise of
democratic socialism which it's really
not and it really makes me sad when the
Left misses the forest for the trees and
that is exactly what is going on here
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com/scishow you can make a
pledge of as little as $1 per month and
every dollar helps to support the work
that we're doing particularly in light
of the YouTube ad boycott which has been
really bad